i'm very excited today oh boy am i
excited
why am i excited danny devito oh i'll
tell you
that's right youtube sent me i
put 50 million play button let's it's
too big to fit the office so i'm just
going to take you with me
look how big that box is i can't even
fit it through
god damn it there's two boxes i wonder
what's inside oh i'm nervous a guy flew
in from new york
just with this package delivering it to
me you know what it is because you read
the title
i don't know what it is i'm so nervous
i'm shaking
[Music]
i don't know what it is with packages
that is so [ __ ] exciting
i really wish i could just be an
unboxing channel that would just be so
much fun
okay should we start with the small one
it's so late i usually don't record this
leg but i'm
can't wait any longer okay the small one
has a bunch of garbage in it
what the hell is this is this the 50
golden play buttons i asked for
oh do you see that that's the brofist
it's a little smaller than expected i
guess wait what's in the other one
wait what the [ __ ] is this
it's this tiny little brofist this is
not what i
i don't mean to sound ungrateful but
what the hell is this surely one of them
is different
what the [ __ ] is this it's all brofist
let's open the big one jesus christ it's
heavy
okay all right here we go
here we go we got foam
whoa
oh my god it's so cool
it's in wood it's saying wood guys
oh it feels amazing this is like
different texture than this
oh i would rub my body all over this are
you guys
are you guys ready i'm nervous i'm
shaking
i don't usually get excited but when you
get a package
this size
you know when i was a small channel i
dreamt of youtube
doing something like this this is a
weird
weird dream come true okay let's just
say that oh my god how deep is this
god damn it
holy [ __ ] guys oh my god holy [ __ ]
oh my god you won't believe this
look how much bubble wrap oh
i love it oh hours of entertainment
let's open the box oh my god
[ __ ] [ __ ] jason
ah it's
oh it's so [ __ ] heavy ugh
i can barely hold it like that i mean i
have the muscles
okay first of all
i mean sorry first of all we did this
that's right i'm talking to you right
now we did this together
me and my bros starting off in my tiny
shitty [ __ ] flat in sweden just
falling in love with making videos and
falling in love with
with you bros that sounds a little
cheesy but i love the interaction
between you guys
i was excited when we hit 30 subs and i
loved it ever since
thank you for subscribing to my channel
thank you
we did this now let's open it together
by me doing all the work
oh we still got nothing okay
okay here we go i'm nervous
oh [ __ ] okay
i see now about the first part
congratulations pewdiepie 50 million
subscribers
holy [ __ ] it looks like a
giant it's supposed to be a ruby but it
looks like those popsicles that you suck
on
i will suck on you i mean this
oh that's cool look at this
oh it's got the brofist it's a custom
that's really [ __ ] cool an exclusive
ultra
rare it smells it smells lovely
now youtube has a way where you can see
who's your lo longest
lasting subscribers that is still active
you know
i'm gonna reach out to one two three
four five six
i'm so glad they did this seven
seven of you bros i'm gonna send out to
my oldest
and most active subscribers because you
guys made this possible
just as much as i did it that really
means a lot to me and i want to honor
that so i'm really happy that they sent
these out that's really sweet
i've got one more
that i'll give away if you leave a
comment and a message
that i'll appreciate and like leave a
like i don't know why not why not beg
for likes
i know i [ __ ] a lot on youtube and i
don't want it to seem like just
because they did this for me um
like all the problems has gone away just
taking all that aside for a minute
youtube really has given me everything
it's given me so many opportunities
uh it's made my life from being in a
very
terrible place to an amazing life that i
could never have even dreamed of having
um it's thanks to you bros but without
youtube
none of this would have happened and i i
don't want to take that for granted
um i don't want to seem ungrateful in
that way youtube really has given me
so much and it's just been an incredible
journey that i'll
never ever forget i am incredibly proud
of reaching 50 million subscribers um
i'm proud of so many people
um it's not just me this is not just me
i don't want it to seem like that way i
won't i just i i own a big thanks
to youtube thank you congratulations
pewdiepie 50 million subscribers
so it has my youtube logo
and the brofist is coming out of it it
looks [ __ ] awesome
what if i drop it and break could that
be
let's not do that oh my god there it is
oh yeah oh um so it's so heavy
i'm so scared of dropping it i would
suck it i would suck it if i could
it looks like one of those popsicles you
know
is that weird okay remember you get a
chance to win one of these they're
really cool
there's only eight of them i'll i'll
sign the i'll sign the bottom of it i'm
going to give out to you bros who
supported me from the beginning and
just finally from the bottom of my heart
thank you for subscribing and watching
me throughout the years
it's made my wildest dreams come true
you know now that i have this it just
hit me
i won't be needing this now
all clean
[Music]
by the way there's one more thing as you
can tell
we have to move office again we're
getting kicked out
one more time
where's my fake tears
[Music]
for me it pains me to do this but the
only way that we can afford
to change office oh my god it's yourself
with that plate but
we're gonna be homeless i'm gonna list
it on ebay
check out the link in the description
and if you want you can buy the dog as
well
i don't want him i don't like you you
know i sold my
i sold my golden plate button really
fast so i hope i can
sell this one equally fast okay cool
great
thank you i give you five thank you very
much
and it's hard appreciate it it's yours
thank you very much
thank you very much thanks felix have a
good one
um i'm gonna start the bidding at one
dollar and hopefully we can sell it
it's it's rough times out there right
now i'm i almost had to delete my
channel
other things you know it pains me to do
this this is like
as if leo had to sell his oscar
goodbye it's been nice having it
there it is i hope
it gets sold i mean i practically barely
used it
okay if you bid now you might get it
before christmas
but yeah check out the link in the
description thank you guys so much for
this play button i wish i could have it
for a little longer but you know
it's just how it's gonna go thank you
guys for watching and dropping a like
even though it
clearly doesn't do anything and as
always
stay awesome bros